and even if you don't know it i want you
to commit to it oh yeah all right i
always i want a conversation between
han solo and chewbacca got it
uh hey chewie listen if we're going to
get to the gaga gigabot
we got to pick up that kid and leia over
on the moon of endor yeah what do you
think of that chewie
i say we better get going
that's the best chewy because you did
the translation
well of course you want to know what the
[ __ ] he's saying yeah yeah thank you so
much i say we get going hon yeah all
right
did you eat did we eat no
let's see when we get there yeah all
right you want to go to that yeah that
place yeah yeah i like that place you
know i chewie lost me during one of the
the newer movies
how
um
one day
like there was a scene where you know
those
were were um luke skywalker with the the
the [ __ ] island he was living on
oh recently the water island right right
right right he was like just a hermit on
a water island right right right and
there was these cute little
penguin things that were like they're
trying to mar they market it as toys
right
and there was a scene where
they showed the two penguins watching
chewbacca trying to eat something and
on a grill or whatever rotisserie he had
killed one of those corgi things awesome
right yeah and i walked out of the
[ __ ] theater no you didn't i did and
i walked back in yeah but it infuriated
me yeah yeah
why would chewie do that because he's a
[ __ ] he's a stupid wolf he's just
like a dog
he's just like lulia no but he has more
cognitive like reasoning though yeah no
he is a he is a
humanoid kind of uh what how is that
different from a human eating pig beef
and other cute little animals yeah we
eat all sorts of cuteness and okay but
in a movie like okay first
i've never seen a movie where some guy
right right is like
eating a steak right and there's two
cows watching them going who yeah you
know what i mean so like you know that's
why i mean i know
in real life if i oh yeah that is weird
those things
he ate one of those things man in front
of them yeah in front of their man yeah
absolutely [ __ ] up yeah it is weird it
would be like it would be i'm shocked
that they didn't do that like in 1987
return of the jedi chewie just eaten
ewoks
yeah right same thing it's the same
concept these guys are cute but ewoks
talk yeah and yeah there's literally
like now the tauntaun scene in empire
strikes back i get that the tantana was
already dead it was already and they
never ate them but they used them as
insulation yeah yes that's okay that's
perfectly fine whereas if chewie was
like it's cold here on this water island
and he just stomped through right with
those cute little guys mouths yeah and
wore them as slippers that would be
that would be weird using them for
warmth yeah or if one of them naturally
oh you know it could be right i i don't
know what the concept behind it but um
or how the cork well i don't know what i
think they're called corgi i don't know
porgs porks yeah i don't know how that
pork diet but what if the pork had
already been dead that could have been
yeah but if you have any type of
intelligence you never just pick up a
dead animal and eat it because you don't
know how it died right so he did murder
it yeah so yeah yeah yeah chewie would
either rub his face into a dead porg or
cook kill and cook a live one yeah yeah
yeah i would i would try one though
during the credits of of that movie it
should have just been chewy on a killing
spree
and preparing them in different ways
like maybe right like a like a you know
like a a porg poke pokey yeah uh
yeah or you know you know like a ceviche
kind of thing yeah and then like
grilling and frying them or doing all
sorts of tick tocks what i would do
if i was a director i would just do one
where you're pounding the meat yeah
right and then do the
the the cutlet they cut like they cut
yeah let's make a pork cutlet yeah like
a cupcake like a katsu you know what i
mean see that and i would eat that if
there was like a star wars themed
restaurant yeah at like disneyland or
disney world yes and it's like pork
cutlets yes you know and the kids are
crying and you're like
just chicken relaxed yeah yeah yeah we
need more like uh child abuse at theme
parks like when we were kids what do you
mean well we were always forced to eat
like you're eating pluto but goofy's
certainly
you ever eat at that restaurant yeah
yeah yeah i used to go to this place in
i would specifically go to vegas
to go to the star trek experience